A truck driver strike over diesel prices had paralyzed much of Brazil.
Halting food and fuel deliveries as main highways were blocked.
Then on Friday, after hearing the army would be sent in to clear the roads,...
...the main truckers union told drivers to abandon the blockade.
But the crisis may not be over for President's Michel Temer's government.
As the Abcam union is encouraging drivers to continue protesting...
...and not make any deliveries.
Food supplies are low in shops and markets.
Many schools have shut and vital services...
...such as rubbish collection had been badly hit.
Brazilians are frustrated and worried as prices go up...
...and supplies run down.
The produce arrived last week, this week nothing arrived.
Eggs that were 80, today are 120.
Potatoes that were 80 for a bag has gone up to 300 to 400.
And petrol stations still have no fuel.
An economic calamity for a road reliant country...
...that's bigger than the United States.